et c'est que vous dites que vous
conformer à la loi mercier et que donc
maintenant vous veillez à ce que les
mineurs on est plus accès au site mais à
partir de quel moment commence
l'exposition des mineurs à des images
pornographiques
est ce qu'il est nécessaire que les
images soit animée j'ouvre votre site je
vais je tape jackie et michel finck et
vous devrez non en fait puisque vous
avez à nouveau deux groupes mais
vraiment sur lequel vous êtes connu dit
avec les michel et et je tombe sur des
pages totalement accessible j'ai juste
cliquer sur je suis majeur ce qui était
sa portée de n'importe quels mineurs et
je trouve des quantités d'image
pornographique
donc
les images ne pornographiques non animés
sont à monsieur gunther pourquoi pas les
sortir la monf h pour montrer j'ai fait
une petite qu'à petites captures d'écran
que j'ai pu enfin je vais vous montrer
ce que tu en veux pas je devrais être
comme moi clic et vous verrez et vous
avez des têtes des quantités d'image
dont j'ai pas d'écrire pour le public la
teneur puisque tout le monde peut faire
ce que j'ai fait donc les mineurs sont
exposés simplement par le fait d'entrer
sur votre site à des images
pornographiques
pourquoi vous considérez pas que
l'accès à la simple page de garde
possibilités j'ai fait défiler chercher
les catégories j'ai plein de matches
beaucoup d'image pourquoi vous
considérez que vous êtes en conformité
avec le droit alors que toutes ces
images sont visibles vous voulez que je
voulais passe
merci
écoutez je vous laisse répondre à ces
différentes questions ou interpellation
alors sur le fait que vous ayez pu
accéder à des images pornographiques
même temps animée alors même que le site
proposé la
lute imai tim pass m'étonne beaucoup
effectivement noir mais je vous crois je
vous demande pas du tout est à vérifier
c'est un outil qui a été créée par nos
équipes en interne pour pour ce but donc
alors il a pu se passer un
dysfonctionnement technique mais je peux
vous assurer que c'est la nature même
de ce logiciel on va dire est qu'il est
appliqué sur l'ensemble de nos sites
donc s'il ya eu un problème technique
ponctuelles
merci nous leur signaler mais
[Musique]